foreign
you're not gonna let go of these jokes
right
no
[Music]
um
foreign
[Laughter]
straight skunk
I feel a Pew [ __ ] hey let's find
out if he stinks
go go work go
back to work
um
[Laughter]
foreign
Mississippi
is
killing me you look nervous you look
nervous he's like nah everything's
simple I'm not nervous uh what would you
do in your spinner
thank you
that's a little bit too honest is that a
is that a hickey on your neck well well
how
[Laughter]
um
I actually like that actually I don't
like hickeys I don't leave them see
that's that's the girl you can [ __ ] with
yeah like yeah you be trying to do
something download with a woman should
be out here leaving Mark something yeah
she's pissed on you
hints
this is not a Scooby-Doo detective tail
you ain't got to leave no [ __ ] hits
for nobody to figure no [ __ ] out I'm
sorry I left my panties
so you just walked out without noticing
that you you forgot you you yeah yeah
you just forgot you was like booba naked
outside no in the streets
I
am
foreign foreign
leave please
leave the table and the thing is like
America I feel like we'd be more about
around the bush yeah uh I Don't Wanna Be
they just they just they don't care you
know the difference between Eastern
European America Americans shave the
bush they beat around it Europeans what
bush
foreign
I thought it was Biden
who's Bush
yeah
this is so Random you like Place yeah
Shakespeare what play from Shakespeare
Romeo and Juliet I'm an Othello fan get
the [ __ ] out
these people are just looking for yeah
yeah yeah yeah they just murky
[ __ ]
he said 24 [ __ ] you look like 24 going
on 37. yeah
you look like I don't know
you did worse yeah when this guy said
he's a student he means he's a student
of life okay he's one of the old sages
living in the mountains okay there's
nothing about this man that says Young
boy
he went like
you know what he did he's like hey man
give me a little tribute to Fat Joe lean
back
[Applause]
I say she doesn't deserve me ready
what's up he's like yo live here hot
like lava what's up yeah I'm just a
hillbilly ding ding ding ding ding on
your [ __ ]
ah
[ __ ] was that noise hillbilly noise
[ __ ] wings
I don't know why you made that noise I
thought the n64. you know what I thought
of Banjo and Kazooie
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I was [ __ ] passed out that's romantic
chop me
like a European [ __ ] difference
[Applause]
all right well bye do you want to stay
yep
Nepal chicken
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's go I don't know if you're still
alive but if you are that was fire
Hey listen that was a 10 out of 10. man
you know what I I said that the
ukrainians don't say any chance but they
look like Fighters
I didn't believe them CNN reports but I
believe this video
[Music]
should kids come
here
[Applause]
people we don't [ __ ] with the popo
is he gay is he gay he said no he's a
cop there's no [ __ ] difference
that's no [ __ ] difference
she said I don't want to get arrested if
I hurt her yeah
maybe he's just talking about her
feelings
everybody heard that she's like he gonna
beat that ass and down in the way that
women like she's here today
[Music]
okay let me ask you do you think that
when we're watching American shows that
just sound cringy because like like you
know people English speakers should just
do a lot of like corny [ __ ] or is it
because we understand the language so we
can't detect the corniness that Eastern
European would if they were hearing this
um I think everybody had a different
this uh perception of what corny is
that's fair definitely there's a
perception there all right
um I think that video was just funny
more than corny yeah despite of the
differences and stuff right but
um we think American shows
American shows are made to be corny
because we like corny we like to make
fun of corny what should I say we like
to make fun of that so that's what sells
if something is like 100 not corny then
it's not it doesn't do as good as yo did
you see this corny [ __ ] yes because we
like to make fun of it so I don't know
how
it is in Eastern Europe and stuff like
that but that I will say this we do
enjoy our our like side of corniness or
cringy yes okay
[Music]
she's like
I want you to talk to me you need to
dominate the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] you
need to go in I need to call you Daddy
and that's hierarchy right there she
looked like she was disappointed she
about to bust this [ __ ] out that's
fine
you should smile more he said that [ __ ]
in America and be like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] patriarchy yeah but you know
yeah over there thank you I really do
feel like here here here
patriarchy is
patriarchy is uh an enemy and over there
betrayarchy is a dish
like it's just it's it's a kind of
potato
ES
yo let's go she said we gonna talk later
talk later I see you I said I already
begged him but I want to see if I can
get some more I'm just saying let's go
you know what's impressive when I'm
watching this also like obviously all
these things are going well so just just
chill to watch it's like um maybe it's
the people they chose but they seem very
comfortable just talking regularly and
having like normal conversations you
know what I'm saying to me this doesn't
make me cringe it's just like a regular
conversation do you like camping
whatever that's what it's supposed to be
that's what I'm trying to say what I
feel like is when I watch a lot of these
dating shows all of it's just cringe
I think it's the way it was casted he
maybe day one people could go for it
Eastern European that are shy
yeah
there's nothing interesting that's going
to come out of that it's yes no question
you don't want to hear a video yeah
all the all the whole time the whole
time yeah whereas yep like you always
have to entice them to answer more
whereas
even when people are shot in the states
or in America
of course there are extremes they can
still
manage to do something every time I hear
and yet it always makes me think of The
Boondocks
[Music]
no when they say [ __ ] they say [ __ ]
who
the Eastern Europeans oh no I noticed
that but I just went out here yet it
makes me think about I went to a
restaurant I went to judge a dance
competition uh talking [ __ ] like
took a picture with me yep and then they
there's a little girl that's a little
girl and you have to understand they
don't have the same anyways
we taking pictures probably one of the
first uh black men that I see and I get
I get tagged on Instagram in one of them
pictures bro I get tagged I get tagged I
get paid
one of the hashtags was [ __ ]
when the hashtag was [ __ ] I was like
but I'm like what's she lying though
get the [ __ ] out of here
I didn't get mad I was like wow we have
different they do different remember
only watching that [ __ ] they were
doing the costume battle and then
decided to come on and full on a black
face yeah we're working yeah yeah it was
a twerking competition yeah but they
don't have the same reality I'm not
saying it's not overtly racist or not
racist I'm just like
I'm gonna make noise over what yeah
hashtag
no hey was that there for today's video
let us know what you asked hashtag [ __ ]